I can't matters okay sisters wash
yourself something we're back we're
[ __ ] back okay oh hello handsome
there you are I just wanted to say
thanks for coming to find me back in
Dawnstar great gesture climbing medicine
actually say thank you there's gonna
give me an idol chill all right [ __ ]
face oh yeah [ __ ] a and my way too
[ __ ] dogs in the way oh there we go
like a shadow Matt I can't second recipe
for disaster
oh [ __ ] you're actually in the building
where is he at there you are took your
sweet time dealing with Cicero mm-hmm
now let's get down to business Astrid
told you about the gourmet I hope mm-hmm
quite so but first you'll need to learn
who is assuming of course that the
gourmet actually is a he ah seems to be
a message from the gourmet to one Anton
voran I believe Oh next you'll have 200
now offered you I can't remember
question 3
there we go let's start this let's start
those are there today I happy hour
countdown because [ __ ] we had a
maid [ __ ] okay yeah I got I got
me and shadow me a [ __ ] I know
doesn't am I lacerated area
yes yes for the hundredth time I am a
breton i was born in high rock and then
I came here what the IMR Richmond who I
am what do you want the gourmet never I
don't know what led you here but nothing
would betray my regard bellowing is like
the start of a gourmets identity to my
grave hood now now wait a minute look
now now you'll let me go okay all right
wonderful you're welcome I'll just be on
my way haha [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] stuff
like that
ok
little way it'll look so good are you
feeling all right
ok
you gotta get out of here hey how can
really hurt they're really [ __ ] hurt
yes come here 10 Al see you have
commissioned confidence Tyra negative
people what say you and you're defacing
that's the best take me to jail alright
prisoner eyes front you're in Sidna mine
now and we expect you to earn your cheap
there's no rest in your hide in a Cell
in this prison here you work your mine
or until you start throwing up silver
bars put the bubonic you'll pay off your
debt to the reach just work and you're
on your freedom alright open er up now
you get down there oh [ __ ] the new meat
so saw tender what was it like killing
the first one huh I left behind my
daughter Molly when I was here the [ __ ]
is this my silver or there's a stocking
minecraft other prisoners get to what do
you think you doing
Oh
yeah I can take that item ok how do i
get adam joy oh okay i gotta tell my god
Matt got it
[ __ ] that's my deck
[Music]
is this much else where I like cause
it's not too bad
yes
save my time of jail
okay yeah sighs will attract it there
well that's a sick [ __ ] our holy [ __ ]
the Shadow Man thank you
well it's cooler ice actually [ __ ]
break such creeped out just freaked out
so shell with a fashion editor I think
shadow we can die let's get cleaned up
with it so [ __ ] y'all hate it okay
that's where I gotta go [ __ ]
stay here shine America once you get
hurt where's the patch
whatever it is I'm too I can't be avail
oh okay that's very easy
well what the [ __ ] is that loop the
hchildress market okay
pour it back [ __ ] bag now let's level
12 holy [ __ ] okay where's that [ __ ]
crystal we're now a shadow scale I serve
Astrid and this sanctuary life is simple
and good
so good i also received word from mark
on it would seem hanson Moran's and
suffered an untimely fate but
unfortunately that useless there's your
gold Lugosi Astrid thanks that I'm the
movement into the Emperor is finally
caught in the end I relied on a woman's
natural wedding repair yeah